hier sachen für sie parat wenn sie doch
noch mal hardcore das ist nur an dass
ich das erlebe ich fühle mich gut
die fehler gemacht ich bin zwar massiv
stefanie weiß nicht ob profi vertrag
glaube dass die sind nur zurückkommen
die grosskinder sind weg vom vater
entführt zurück bleibt eine schmerzhafte
lehre von einem kampf in dem es nur
verlierer gibt aufgeben aber trotzdem
keine option ist
davon handelt dieser film
mit deiner sendung natürlich sehr viel
kartoffeln ganz real
es ist entweder sie bemerkte dieter k
da sind für sie mit dem taxi erschossen
worden
wenn ich das schaffe
wie jede so hat auch diese geschichte
zwei seiten
wir erzählen jene der familie traxel und
reisen dafür nach kairo in der
ägyptischen hauptstadt wollen wir uns
mit christine traxis tochter karin
treffen
karin traxel führt uns zu ihrer
momentanen unterkunft um ihren beiden
töchtern möglichst nahe zu sein ist die
primarschul leiterin von interlaken nach
kairo gezogen
die mädchen waren zwei und vier jahre
alt als ihr ex-mann dies in seiner
heimat ägypten entführte mittlerweile
sind zwei jahre vergangen
zwischen zuversicht und zermürbung die
kinder haben und sie erneut verlieren
zum zeitpunkt unseres besuchs hat karin
traxel eine ihrer töchter die ältere
zurückerkämpft die jüngere ist beim
vater es ist offensichtlich die monate
der trennung führten zur entfremdung
die angst vor mir und die klinik mit
und theoretisch unicom das ist das
letzte bild von der mutter mit ihren
beiden töchtern
das foto entstand vor rund zehn monaten
so lange hat karen traxel ihre jüngere
tochter nicht mehr sehen dürfen
kontakt
geburtstag des telefonierens probiert
derzeit geburtstag will sie festhalten
wenigstens die eine tochter und diesen
fragilen moment der zweisamkeit mit nur
an ausreisen ist ohne väterliche
erlaubnis oder richterliche verfügung
straf und für karry traxel auch
undenkbar nicht ohne jüngere tochter im
ringen um die kinder integrierten tiefer
in die mauern dicker geworden
dabei stand auch hier am anfang der
romantische glaube an ein eigenes
familienglück
die sprachschule und religiöser werte
es folgte die trennung der angestrebte
frieden aber blieb aus
ihr ex-mann so erzählt uns karin traxel
drohte ihr damit die kinder zu entführen
außer reisepässe beantragen will
versucht sie dies zu verhindern
vergeblich
das regionalgericht tun sprich dem vater
das recht auf fähren mit den kindern in
seinem heimatland zu im sommer vor zwei
jahren fliegt der schweizerische
doppelbürger mit den gemeinsamen
töchtern in den urlaub und kehrt nicht
mehr zurück
anfänglich gab karin traxel noch man
könne mitreden eine lösung finden
zusammen mit ihren eltern und einem
dolmetscher reist sie nach ägypten zu
ihrem ex mann und dessen familie
wer den 14 tage später 18 jährige
cousine was schon ihre familie bleibt
mir sicher keine tier onyx ist das
präsentiert die neue freiheit zu mir
nach entlocken
diana präsentiert als quasi die neue
mutter der glaube an eine friedliche
lösung ist längst erloschen
der kampf um beide kinder hingegen
entbrannt karen traxel geht nun
rechtlich gegen ihren ex-mann vor
ein ungleicher kampf in einem fremden
land mit fremder kultur und fremder
gesetzgebung
sie fühlt sich machtlos und ausgeliefert
von den verantwortlichen behörden zu
wenig unterstützt
wir fragen beim eidgenössischen amt für
auswärtige angelegenheiten eda nach und
erfahren dass das eda im fall traxel bei
verschiedenen stellen in bern und kairo
interveniert hat aber selbst ein treffen
mit dem ägyptischen justizminister und
ein telefongespräch mit dem büro des
präsidenten bleiben wirkungslos
es gilt das ägyptische gesetz und nach
diesem hat der vater keine straftat
begangen
karin traxel hat auf eigene faust einen
ägyptischen anwalt engagiert und mit
seiner hilfe auch in ägypten das
sorgerecht der beiden mädchen bekommen
ein teilsieg aber die hiesigen behörden
setzten den entscheid nicht um mannes
willen und dringlichkeit das zurzeit
wenigstens eine tochter bei ihr lebt ist
glückssache
ein handel mit dem ex mann sein
wohlwollen so werden wir später sehen
schlägt schon bald wieder in
feindseligkeit um
will das fiel bei interlaken das zuhause
der familie traxel wir lernen auch karin
bruder und den jüngsten spross der
familie kennen
trotz freude über den zuwachs es drücken
die sorgen um die tochter und die
enkelkinder neuerdings auch ums geld
die familie steht vor dem finanziellen
ruin
an die 400.000 franken haben die traxel
sind zweijährigen kampf um die kinder
ausgegeben und die mädchen sind immer
noch nicht daheim in interlaken
einziger lichtblick für die großmutter
enkel an wie ich für sie aus wie eine
gurke
das kann man im gut machen 202 jahren
brutal twitter wo nachspiel nicht
absehbar harz finanziell oder einfach
gemerkt wenn man nicht selber initiative
ergriffen
versucht mit spendensammler benefits
dass man von ihm unterstützte damals
schon von der behörde völlig im stich
die vorschläge wo man immer wieder hört
ja ganze doch alle gedanken gespielt
aber da gibt es natürlich sehr schwierig
mit dieser legale weg brachte der mutter
immerhin eine tochter zurück nur eine
zwischenlösung das ist klar
die beziehung zwischen mutter und
tochter wird von tag zu tag stärker
das zutrauen wächst es ist
weihnachtszeit mit kritikern zu backen
versuch karin traxel ein stück schweizer
normalität in den für das kind und sie
belastenden alltag zu bringen
karen traxel ist bewusst dass eine
rückkehr nach interlaken für die kinder
erneut eine entwurzelung ist das für die
zukunft ein stück heile welt im
ausnahmezustand
fünf mal in kurzer zeit haben mutter und
tochter die unterkunft gewechselt aus
angst vor dem vater ort installiert sie
ich wieder irgendwas passiert zu sein
mit kontakten und passstraßen tochter
schon früher also noch beide kinder
hatte habe er ihr gedroht
telefon oder video telefonie
das ist einfach ein entscheidender
moment gemeinsam steigen wir ins auto
das ziel dieser fahrt ist das haus des
kindesvaters karen traxel will zusammen
mit ihrem anwalt ein gerichts
vollstrecker und der polizei ihre
jüngere tochter sarah
zweimal schon hat sie es auf diesem wege
versucht beide male hat der vater zuvor
wind bekommen und ist mit den mädchen
abgehauen auf dem weg klingelt das
telefon
es ist ein mittelsmann er stoppt das
unterfangen
anscheinend fände eine anhörung statt
ihr ex mann wolle ihr das sorgerecht
wieder entziehen lassen
der grund der anhörung ist unklar ich
habe ihn gefragt ob sie dort sein
es sei aber nur sein anwalt es ist wohl
nicht nötig dass wir dort erscheinen
wir gehen jetzt zu seinem büro wieder
eine wende stadt zu einem wiedersehen
mit sarah führt uns diese aktion in
einen hinterhof
hier ist das büro des informanten und
hier erfahren wir es geht um ein foto
welches ihr ex mann dem richter
vorgelegt haben soll
anscheinend zeigt dass karen traxel mit
einem anderen mann fatal sollte die
mutter sich neu winken riskiert sie das
sorgerecht zu verlieren
ich weiß nicht was für ein foto das ist
sie müssen prüfen wer das ist und vor
allem was das für ein anlass war ein
weiterer rückschlag
auch wenn sie später beweisen lässt dass
es sich beim foto um eine alte aufnahme
handelt
von karen traxel und einem ihrer mit
studenten an der fasnacht er nicht wir
wird ihre sympathie haben wir müssen auf
legalem weg weitermachen
darum braucht es mehr kraft und energie
die hoffnung auf ein wiedersehen wurde
soeben jäh zerschlagen
und es kommt noch schlimmer nachdem wir
hier anfang jahr in ägypten gefilmt
haben
macht der vater die drohung wahr und
entführt die ältere tochter erneut eine
von ihm angeheuerte männer bahn der
schlecker in traxel nieder und entreißt
ihr das kind letzte woche daheim bei der
großmutter karin traxel berichtet uns
via skype vom überfall
es geschah sie nur an zum schulbus
brachte der ägyptische schulbusfahrer
der vor ort helfen wollte bezeugt die
tat wegen anstiftung zur
körperverletzung wird ihr ex-mann
erstinstanzlich zu einem jahr gefängnis
verurteilt
für die traxlers ein strohhalm doch der
kindesvater legt berufung ein
das ist nun vier monate her da sind die
mädchen verschwunden
nach zwei jahren kampf das kinderzimmer
bleibt leer
gestern fand das berufungsverfahren
wegen anstiftung zu körperverletzung
statt
ihr ex mann kam auf kaution frei das
urteil steht noch aus
und die kinder keine spur der vater hält
sie weiterhin versteckt im streit um die
töchter so der richter sollen sich die
beiden parteien selber finden
somit ist auch dieser strohhalm geknickt
trotz emotionaler erschöpfung die praxis
werden weiter kämpfen weil der rest
funke hoffnung auf ein leben mit den
kindern niemals erwischt